المصائب تويتر عند متى فوائد يبدو ان متى
قاعده تحاول استثمار الازمات التي يعيشها
تويتر لتكون منافسه له في اهم ميزاتها
القائمه في النصوص القصيره متى مشاهدينا
عبر تطبيقها انستقرام تسعى ان يكون شهر
يونيو المقبل هو شهر اشهر التطبيق الجديد
خبراء تكنولوجيا يعتقدون ان تطبيق مثل
جديد سيكون منافسا قويا لتويتر خصوصا وان
يقوم على فكره الاعتماد على الموستائين من
تويتر في عصر ايلون ماسك الشركه الام
للفيسبوك قد تعمق ازمه تويتر لا سيما وانا
تطبيق المنتظر قد يسحب بساط المؤثرين من
تويتر
الى
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا اصانع المحتوى
والمؤثر في تقنيه المعلومات فيصل السيف
بونجورنو صباح الخير
يا صديقي
تحس انه ما كان
يصير باستغلال فرص وهو في مجال استقطاب
العدد الاكبر من المستائين ام ماذا
جميل جدا صبحك الله بالخير
فعليا اغتنام الفرص نعم نقدر نسميها كذا
خاصه انه في بعض التحفظات على نفس التطبيق
تويتر بالتغييرات اللي قاعده تصير
والتعديلات من ايلون ماسك صارت تتطلب
الاشتراك لبعض المستخدمين والمؤثرين وايضا
صار فيها تقليل المحتوى بشكل واضح جدا من
سياسات نفس التطبيق انستغرام قاعده تحاول
انها تتصيد نقدر نقول الفرص بانه التطبيق
اللي قاعد يصير على نفس المغردين تنشئ لهم
منصه هذه المنصه يكونوا اقرب للناس من
خلالها ولكن هل هذا امر وارد بانه ينتشر
هل التطبيق الجديد صدقا مستبعد جدا
في منطق بس يعني انا حابه اعرف الاسباب
لانه مثلا طلع كتير في منصات جديده مثل
تبعت
ترامب وفي غيرها من المنصات ولكن على ما
يبدو احنا دائما ما الحب الا للحبيب الاول
فلي تعودنا عليه بالبدايه راح نضلنا معه
عادي نقطه جدا ممتازه تطبيق تعودنا عليه
اكثر من عشره سنوات وبالتالي هذا
وبالتالي هذا التطبيق طبيعته ما بين
النصوص والصور والفيديوهات الطبيعه
المتزنه اللي وصلت له هذه الطبيعه هي اللي
نحتاجها على المنصه انستجرام تعودنا عليها
كتطبيق فعلي للصور والفيديوهات قاعدين
يحاولوا اخر ثلاث سنوات يحولوه الى تطبيق
اكثر الفيديوهات نوعا ما قادرين ينجحوا
بزاويه ولكن لو سالتكم الحين كم منكم
يستخدم انستجرام ماسنجر واللي موجود صار
له اكثر من سنه حق المراسلات ماسنجر
اصلا شكرا
فهنا نقدر نقول انه صعب جدا تيجي وتاخذ
جزئيه ضخمه من المستخدمين لتطبيق اخر ولكن
ممكن تستحوذ على الجزء من اصلا اللي
موجودين عندك يعني خليني اقول فيصل
انستغرام بلش هو عباره عن البوم صور قبل
ان يتحول الى البوم للفيديو التعليق
المكتوب او النص هو عباره عن تعليق على
صوره او رد على احد يتحدث معك لكن تويتر
هي الحاله اللي انت تعيشها ربما النوت في
الانستقرام وهو استحداث جديد قبل فتره صار
بس قاعد يقول ما هي الحاله اللي انت
تعيشها هل ينجح بانه يكون تطبيق مستقل ولا
ضمن انستجرام
بالنجاح بشكل اكبر كون انه تويتر من احد
الاشياء المهمه الاساسيه واللي كمان تعرفت
عليها انه تعودنا عليه بطبيعته وايضا
الناس اللي موجودين فيه لما نكون موجودين
على تويتر ننتظر قرارات ومعلومات من اشخاص
اساسيين لم يتواجدوا بلحظه كذا على طول
ينتقلوا الى تطبيق فاعلي هم موجودين اصلا
وعارفين انه رسميتهم سواء لما نتكلم من
افراد وزارات او شركات او منصات او حتى
دول متواجدين بشكل رسمي فهذا التواجد
الرسمي هو اللي مخلينا على المنصه ما في
اي سبب قوي الى الحين خاصه لو قلنا انه
منصه نصوص فقط على انستجرام ما في اي شيء
قوي خلينا ننجذب الى هذه البساطه بعد ما
صار في الاثراء العادي اللي موجودين احنا
في الحين وحتى اصلا جمهور تويتر مختلف
تماما عن جمهور انستغرام
اهتمامات مختلفه انتهى وقت شكرا جزيلا لك
المؤثر وصانع المحتوى في تقنيه فيصل السيف
كان معنا
بالخير
يمس الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات